what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
man let's raise some dude the Batman
whoo laughs do this story do this story
man this story is so good you know every
once in a while you come across Batman's
story James tinny ins man dude this guy
man do you man okay let's let's let's
let's get into this let's get let's
explain the Batman whoo laughs all right
first things first y'all need to go out
to the store buy this comic because it's
like it's like three bucks do this crazy
how good this comic is you guys got to
go buy this thing because it's
absolutely insane like it's it is
definitely one of my favorites but the
cool thing about this is that this opens
up with the bat and who lasts himself
the Batman who laughs is jumping into
like tarot card reading but the cool
thing is that the the way that it's done
you know with my lack of knowledge about
heroes the way that's done is it
highlights the nature of the Joker right
about how the Joker is insane that Joker
is crazy
but the Joker is always you know also
one of those wild cards that can shift
up everything in its entirety and so
what it does is it switches to earth- 22
which is you know quite some time ago
and the cool thing about this is Joker
has Batman captive now we've seen this a
million times before that's one of the
crazy things about this is a lot of the
stuff that unfolds here for the most
part it's par for the course it's just
Batman defeating the Joker the crazy
thing about this is the Joker in this
universe seems to be experiencing a
level of insanity that we've never seen
before and the reason I mean that is
because in truth like historically
speaking if you look at the history of
the Joker in DC Comics he's basically
waxed and waned over the years when he
first popped up in DC he was really dark
he was really sinister the old Bob Kane
Bill Finger Joker was super sadistic
then the comics code kicked in and for
something like you know 60 years the
Joker was basically toned down in goofy
who was a port where he came back and he
was a little dark for a while maybe I
like the 60s or 70s that was about it I
mean when you go and read most Joker
comics he's nonsensical he's goofy the
Joker that we got in scott Snyder's new
52 run of Batman death of a family
in-game though that's the Joker that's
just reminiscent to the old-school Joker
that we saw way back in you know the
1930s but the crazy thing about this is
that with Joker having seemed too
emotionally snapped not only has he
captured Batman he kills the family of a
girl and then in turn exposes the girl
to a joke to the Joker toxin so it's
pretty intense because it's basically
his goons his henchmen that have all
these families lined up in Gotham City
waiting for the Joker to do them in
because all the Joker's doing is
repeating Batman's history now there's
something that I hope you notice about
this the kind of things bad that that
Joker says I can break anybody you know
I just I realize what was going on one
day Jim Gordon tried to get into the way
and then of course I made Jim Gordon
break this is very reminiscent of The
Killing Joke for those of you guys who
never read The Killing Joke that was a
story where it was the whole point Joker
was making was that all it takes is one
bad day one bad day and a person can be
broken that was the origin story of The
Joker back in the day and a lot of
people still say it is the Joker's
origin because BC is really kind of
hinted at that being the case for the
most part over the years but the whole
idea was that the Joker was just a guy
who was in the wrong place at the wrong
time he'd lost his job he fell him with
some mobsters who promised easy money he
had a wife and a kid on the way so the
temptation for that easy money was very
very high he ultimately agreed to the
demands only to be set up as the fall
guy he ended up in a fight with Batman
he fell into of that and when he emerged
his hair was green his face was white
and his lips were red and he lost his
mind and that's the point of The Killing
Joke all it ever takes is one bad day
and the goal of the Joker was to break
Commissioner Gordon by basically
injuring his daughter and then in turn
subjecting him to photos overall he was
sitting Jim Gordon through this horrific
rollercoaster and then to try to do the
same thing with Batman this story ended
ambiguously it ended with the question
did Batman kill the Joker did Batman let
him go Grant Morrison argued that Batman
killed the Joker earthing it was but the
writer Alan Moore has never said either
way and so in truth there's no
definitive answer it's just whatever
answer it is that people want to choose
to believe which is why they're killing
jokes one of the best stories out there
because the nature of the story the
ending creates this massive argument
between fans over what happened between
Batman and the Joker Batman just starts
laughing and then it says the Laughing
dies and that's it and so we don't know
what ends up happening in that story the
interesting thing about this is that it
is again an attempt of the Joker to
break Batman and it's almost like
Batman's this immutable force because
we're Joe where Batman says you have to
stop you have to quit
Joker's responses never I will never
ever ever stop all the things that we've
seen over the years especially recently
when it came to the Joker's story you
know in new 52 the Joker and Batman are
two sides to the same coin in a lot of
ways one represents order one represents
chaos one can't live without the other
whether it's because Batman
NEADS the Joker in order to believe he's
making some measure of progress whether
it's the Joker because he just needs
order in order to inflict chaos whatever
the case may be they essentially need
each other and that's one of the reasons
why the Joker has always been a kind of
a mainstay it's like this meta
commentary on the nature of Geneva he
can't have one without the other and so
in this instance Batman manages to
overpower the Joker and in doing so
breaks his neck he kills him and so what
this does it just kinda loud a little
bit of this Joker toxin to basically
make its way out and that's really about
it nothing really seems to come of the
death of the Joker and so what we do
from here is we pick up with this
aftermath Batman talking to Superman the
idea that a lot of these kids who had
been subjected to Joker's toxin and
really just kind of had their minds
broken that there may not be any way to
bring them back and that's the case the
Batman makes there's no coming back from
this you know for these kids there's
probably no way to cure them now of
course Superman being hopeful basically
says look there has to be a way we have
to find a way what this does is it picks
up about three days later with the bat
Family Dick Grayson and then Barbara
Gordon and so on and so forth and
they're basically just training and it's
kind of cool because they're facing off
against robots you know but again this
is one of the interesting scenarios
because they make the comment that has
been years since they've experienced
this and in truth it's been years since
we've seen it in the Batman comics
because remember that's the way Batman
works
Batman brings in these kids you know he
brings in Barbara Gordon he brings in to
Grace and he brings in Jason Todd over
the course of his existence as Batman
Bruce Wayne brings these characters in
for a multitude of different reasons
sometimes it's because you know they
lost their parents or the same way Bruce
Wayne did and so he basically adopts
them trained them to learn how to get
revenge to a degree but to also how to
stop crime make Gotham a safer City it's
Batman's surrounding himself with
possible replacements should anything
ever happen to him that's one of the
reasons why every single one of the
members of the bat family have been
trained in a way that makes them almost
as good as Batman is in terms of a
detective almost as good as a fighter at
the whole nine yards because of that the
whole thing begins to sort of unwind
when Dick Grayson makes the comment
things aren't right because it's been
years since they've been subjected to
you know to training you know by Batman
in their whole you know training room
and it's also been a while since
Batman's basically communicated directly
with them for the most part the
indication here is that it's all been
behind like screens or it's been smoke
and mirrors and when they sit down and
they talk with Batman Batman's answer is
when Joker died he infected me with
something he infected me with a perfect
strain of the Joker toxin now
the cool thing about this because
remember on the surface the Joker seems
to be nonsense
for example Heath Ledger's Joker in the
Dark Knight Returns made the comment I'm
not a man with a plan I'm a man who just
does things I'm a dog chasing a car I
wouldn't know what to do if I got it and
so depending on who's riding the Joker
at the time either he is that way where
he's just goofy comedic he has no real
plan he wants to copyright fish
different things like that or if you're
reading scott Snyder's Joker in new 52
he does have a plan he has this great
big huge laid out plan on what he wants
to do and everything that happens seems
to be chaotic but it goes towards an
ideology how do you separate the
nonsense from the truth because the
truth will lead you to the plan but it's
so surrounded and so clouded with
absolute nonsense there's no way to
really know which is true and which is a
lie that's what makes the Joker so
difficult to find not only that where
Batman explains this to the Batman
family their responses look we'll find a
way we'll find a way to cure you Batman
statement is the reason why I brought
you here is because you guys would be
the first ones to know if there was
anything wrong with me and if you told
you know if you thought there was
anything wrong with me you would tell
people and I can't allow that so he
kills them all he kills every last
member of the bad family dude you guys
never saw that common did you he kills
them all Red Hood he goes Dick Grayson
Tim Drake the whole nine yards they all
get done in from there he takes it to
the Justice League now the Justice
League happens off panel we don't
actually see it take place but it is
crazy to see it happen because basically
everybody's been taken out by Batman
except for like Superman he's like the
last man standing now because of the
fact that Batman who last because his
version of Batman is really more attuned
to the Joker as opposed to Bruce Wayne
himself it's not just about defeating
superheroes it's also about inflicting
as much mental anguish as he possibly
can and so what happens is he actually
brings the family of Superman in
Jonathan Kent and Lois Lane what he does
in turn is he not only taunts Superman
he exposes him to black kryptonite now
black kryptonite is one of those weird
scenarios really black kryptonite made
its debut in comic book form in
Supergirl number two in 2005 but if you
go and you look at the history of black
kryptonite as far as I'm aware it
originally appeared in Smallville now
black kryptonite in Smallville was a
plot device more than anything else and
what they did is it basically
established that you can split a being
into one good one evil basically split
their personas in half
regards to the DC Comics landscape if
you read Supergirl number 2 from 2005
sure it'll split people in half one good
one evil if you read all-star Superman
it inverts the moral compass of the of
the Kryptonian that it's used on and
then basically decreases their mental
faculties so they basically become an
evil version who's stupid and so that's
exactly what happens with Superman with
Batman exposing Superman to a modified
strain of black kryptonite it adjusts
its traditional properties of splitting
a being into and instead inverts
Superman to make him a villain who in
turn takes out Jonathan and he takes out
Lois and that's insane and that's a
crazy thing about this because remember
it's not just about taking down Superman
it's about inflicting moral harm on
Superman's psyche now presumably
Superman will never be able to recover
from this he won't be able to come back
from this we never actually find out
what happens we're kind of left to
believe that the Batman who lost takes
him out but all the other superheroes
who unite against him all the other
governments who unite against him the
whole of humanity for the most part is
all taken out and subdued by the Batman
who lost we don't know how but what DC
seems to be doing is grabbing this
concept of Bruce Wayne who's pragmatic
who is analytical who goes through and
analyzes every single situation and then
combined it with the chaotic nature of
the Joker brought those two together and
unleash an absolute nightmare on
humanity which in turn led to the end of
humanity almost in its entirety now
because of the fact that the Batman who
laughs is so extreme and because of the
fact that he is sort of this amazing
combination of the Joker and Batman
merged into a singular being he's the
first to be approached by Barbados now
again we don't know exactly when this
happens we just know what happens before
the origin stories of all the other
members that we've seen of Barbados is
Dark Knight's and the origin stories
we've covered so far so we'll probably
throw this one at the beginning of all
those the whole idea is that because the
Batman who lost has this mind of Bruce
Wayne and this chaos of the Joker he's
basically shown all these different
multi-view these different universes out
there these different earths where
Batman's still exists or where the earth
hasn't experienced the kind of
destruction and the kind of chaos the
Batman who last wants to bring to it
because remember the goal the Joker is
just spread fear and chaos and so with
Barbados coming along and giving him the
opportunity and saying hey look if you
go there there's absolute pandemonium
and destruction then it gives the Batman
who lasts exactly what he's looking for
and so what he began to do is basically
travel around
and find all these dark nights that
exist out there the Red Death and the
Devastator and Dawnbreaker and so on and
so forth all these different members of
the dark knights bind them together and
then bring them in and so what we end up
doing is finding out that the Joker is
talking to an unnamed guy to a guy who's
basically wrapped in bandages the guy I
don't think we ever find out who he is
I'm not a hundred percent sure but the
whole idea here is that he basically
says look the nature of the Joker is
such that it has no real power The
Joker's inspired by fear right like the
Joker uses fear to basically get people
to do what he wants them to do he's very
much the same as Batman in that regard
but where Batman is a fighter and he's a
detective and he has all these different
things at his disposal the Joker has
whatever is around him at the time you
know whatever henchmen he can use
whatever money he can amass and that's
really about it he's got no real power
unto himself the Batman however is the
king of his castle the Batman has it all
the matter has all the tools that he
needs to be able to pull off everything
that he wants to do and so if you take
those two things and you combine them
together and you make the King into the
Joker
then suddenly he is the king of
everything he gives he's basically his
uncontrollable force of nature this
being that does nothing more than use
his intellect to bring about as much
chaos as he possibly can and that's when
he says if you believe that what you've
seen here is the pinnacle if you believe
what you've seen here is as bad as it
gets and then I promise you it will only
get worse because there's all these
different iterations of Batman and not
just Batman all these different
iterations of the Earth's superheroes
that exist out there a version of
Darkseid whose Superman flash with the
body of a spider I mean all of these
just crazy contracted things these
versions of Superman and all these
versions of Batman these versions of
Wonder Woman the flash the Green Lantern
and all these versions exist out there
all these characters are just out there
and again we learned that from the last
story that we covered when Barbados
forced Batman to see all these crazy
things like I've shown you three three
worlds where things are awry where
things are crazy whether absolutely
chaotic but that's three worlds there
are thousands of worlds like this where
things are just absolute pandemonium
they're screwed up all the characters
are bad guys if it's just the worst
nightmares you there possibly imagine
taking form in the dark multiverse then
there are thousands of these nightmares
running around and so again it's crazy
because the prospect is should this and
go off without a hitch then it means
some of the worst nightmares in
existence the worst monstrosity z' of
the characters that we know their worst
versions their worst selves all come
flowing out of this dark multiverse into
the main DC universe and everything goes
to pieces after that with that being
said guys we're gonna go ahead and bring
this video to an end if you are new here
- comments explain make sure you guys
did the sub button to become part of the
robb cork - guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
you